قالت الاداره الاقليميه لكياب ان صواريخ
اطلقت باتجاه العاصمه ودعت السكان للبقاء
في الملاج والاماكن العامه او الامنه عفوا
وكانت السلطات العسكريه في مقاطع الجنوبيه
البلاد افادت عن مقتل مدني واصابه ثلاثه
في قصف دروسي استهدف المدينه الصناعيه
بمدينه كريزيري وقالت هيئه الاركان
الاخرانيه ان قواتها شنت خلال الساعات
الماضيه 19 تسعه 10 غاره على مواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه في اكثر من محور على طول
خطوط التماس وافادت هيئه الاركان
الاخرانيه عن مقتل اكثر من 10 جنودروس
واصابه نحو 30 في قصف الاوكراني استهدف
منطقه
جنوبيه البلاد كما بثت مقطعا مصورا قالت
انه لقياده وحده باللواء الصاروخيه باسقاط
مروحيه روسيه من طراز
اثنين و 50
واكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تصديها
لهجابات القوات الروسيه في 13
بالاضافه الى صدها اربع هجمات على مدينه
باخموطن
افادت سلطات المحليه المواليه لروسيا في
لوكا ان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا واصيب 15 بجروح
في قصف استهدف مناطق عده بالمقاطعه وفي
دنيا قالت السلطات المحليه المواليه
لروسيا اذن 12 شخصا اصيب في قصف الاوكراني
استهدف مناطق بالمقاطعه خلال 24 ساعه
الماضيه واضافت ان القصف الحق اضرارا نحو
40 منزلا مؤكده تعرضا منطقه فوجي
لوفوسكايا فجر اليوم لقصف بعشره صواريخ من
نوع